so i haven't seen any of these questions
so um it started out from a tweet where
someone said like here's 10 questions to
get to know people is that is that right
yeah listener of the pod and i think
your friend blake blake burge i think is
his name uh he had tweeted out a thing
like you know
whatever
there are many questions but few will
change your life here's ten questions
that will change your life and you know
thread goes viral so by the way you know
normally it's kind of like eye roll
no it's good there's this thing ben
you'll have to look it up again no
research here there's this thing i
remember years ago it was called like
the new york times like 21 questions
and it was like here ask these 21
questions on a first year right
well on a first date i thought and it
was like here's how you get intimate
with people and like as a single 21 year
old i read that i was like oh like here
so i can hook up with girls and i
remember those questions and they're
very similar to what these guys
questions are but it was like
when did your father make you cry or
like like it was like pretty deep
questions like that um and so i'm down
with these questions
[Music]
so i actually read these questions and i
was like these are actually good
questions but um
the way he presented it i think uh
you know no offense is how most people
do twitter it's like
here's some general advice or some
general questions
what's interesting to me is not the
quote like the question but it's kind of
seeing somebody struggle with their
their answer to that question so for
example
um he would ask a question like
and i'll give you give you the first
question which is which is going to come
out here in a second so ben read
question number one i'll explain how he
tweeted it and how i think we should
answer instead
read
in what areas of my life am i settling
okay so what area is my life am i
settling that's a powerful question it's
a good thought-provoking question now
his the rest of his tweet was like
you know just enough or just okay is not
good enough identify the areas you like
you're just settling
so to me that's the part where it was
like no no blake i want to hear your
answer like
you tell me like if you're gonna put out
one of these [__] ass threads that's
like you know generic generic generic
thread um to try to get likes
i think that the next level of this like
[__] thread thing is people are
gonna get a little more vulnerable
they're gonna put their actual answers
in the thread rather than general advice
who's invented this this theme i'm
seeing so like upworthy was like here's
ten things you're not gonna believe
number seven this new one that i'm
seeing on twitter is there's eight
thousand of this thing here's the four
best
eight billion humans on this earth not
all of them are worth following here's
my eleven friends that are worth
who created that
well ben all right what's the first one
i just tried it it's uh in what area of
my life
you go first okay so what areas of my
life am i settling
and by the way this is called the boys
go to therapy because we got to open up
a little bit we gotta we gotta see what
the what this what the answer might be i
would say
two come to mind the first is fitness
like
i think i got kind of comfortable with
my
workout routine and diet and i was like
oh okay like not as fat as i was
i'm on my way to getting fit and i just
kind of got okay with like
i was kind of settling for like wow
you're much better than before
but i've been like writing that for for
like you know 12 months now and now the
before is the same as the current
because it's like been a while
like six months of like the same and so
i just realized this recently and was
like why did i settle here this isn't
the destination like i basically was on
a road trip and i stopped at the gas
station and then unpacked my bags
instead of being like no no
this is not the destination this is the
pit stop i gotta get to the hotel
where's my suitcase open you made a lot
of progress so in a relatively short
amount of time you just gotta keep going
yeah so i would say i'm settling there
and the other one i'm settling i think
is me and my wife like we have two
little kids and
there's like you know this feeling of
like you know what like
we put a lot into work okay then you put
you're putting a lot into your fitness
you're putting a lot into your kids
and it's like oh whatever's left over at
the end of the day for each other like
you know we take what we can get as the
scraps uh of like you know the energy
the kind of like um just the effort we
put into kind of your relationship as i
think we've both kind of settled on that
which is like it's fine they're not
they're not leaving they're not going
anywhere it's just fine we can hold you
because we can always do this later when
the kids grow up is she gonna listen to
this no that's the beauty of it
you should never listen to this i think
that that's good that you you said that
maybe uh maybe that will make her like
you more
yeah especially because i didn't say
that she is doing all this right he said
we are doing it which is you know the
key
all right what about you what areas of
your life do you think you're settling
um
my a consistent diet needs to i think i
could i like to improve that i looked at
my goals over the last 10 years so i
created a goal tracking thing 10 years
ago when i was about 21
and i hit all of them except for wanting
to weigh 190 pounds i've always
struggled to lose 10 pounds and i just
i've always wanted to do it i've never
done it and so i've i'm sucking at that
the second thing career-wise i've
settled a bit so i i purposely set up a
period where i was like one year
the sale in plus one year i'm gonna
chill i'm just gonna read i'm gonna
learn and i still am not ready to like
go all in on something i'm not there yet
and so i'm kind of being a little bit
lazy and i feel a little guilt around
that
and then i'll do a relationship one dude
i'm super dependent on sarah like
uh if someone like wants me to come
speak somewhere i'll be like sarah can
you just like handle this or like do you
want me to go speak here like let me
know like i'm only gonna and oftentimes
because i don't like to fly i'll be like
uh by the way i'm only going if you're
available like if you don't go i don't
want to go because i enjoy being around
her and i think i should learn to do a
few things by myself a little bit more
than i have been lately i just tend to
rely on her so freaking much that i need
to i need to go do stuff by myself give
me one that's give me one that's uh a
settle that you i feel like all those
settles maybe that both of us said are
like
settles that we're kind of cool with
what's a settle you're not cool with
the weight thing yeah the weight thing
i'm not cool with that like i get up
like i'm pissed off i'm like why can't i
just be consistent if i was just
consistent for like five months with in
a certain amount of calories i'd be good
i'm i would be good i would hit it but
it is so freaking tempting and i just
give in to that [__] and that pisses me
off um
what else i don't know what am i i do
think that
so tell me if this is a settling thing
i create i've created a couple little
small products in my free time and i get
so excited about making like 500 100 a
thousand dollars a day i get so much joy
from that and i'm like
dude i could crush this if i want to i
can build i can build things that are
huge why am i not why don't i have the
motivation to do this and so i feel like
i feel soft and like i'm settling in
that aspect yeah i think one uh one that
i've seen in myself and by the way i
don't think that that was uh
i forgot what you said you said tell me
what you think about this like i agree
with you so so i think that was good um
i'm thinking more and more that the
the settling thing
the easiest way for me to pinpoint where
i'm settling is when i see the contrast
when i see somebody who's not settled in
this area
and i'm like oh
hmm
they wow they're really pushing it
beyond beyond where i am right now in
this like and it doesn't mean i'm always
going to just chase and do what others
do necessarily but it kind of takes me
seeing that for me to be like
oh word like that's this isn't uh this
isn't the kind of the spot to just
settle down and dig my heels in and so
that's happened to me with money like
for example
i've seen people's lifestyle or i've
seen people's just people talking about
stuff it's like somebody will be like um
yeah we you know we picked up this
project and then we you know like a real
estate deal we
picked up this deal and we're gonna flip
it you know basically four months later
and you know we should make one and a
half million on that and i'm just sort
of like oh okay so like their normal
where they have settled for their normal
is like what would have been let's say
an outstanding outcome for me but like
to them that's the normal course of
business
and then i just sort of check myself and
i say all right do i care and
usually i usually i do care usually i do
care when i notice those things because
that's why they stood out to me in the
first place and like sometimes they
don't stand out in this way that i'm
saying where i'm saying it all calmly
i'm just sort of like usually it's like
i'm jealous of them or i'm like um
i find myself trying to come up with a
reason why that's not good and then i
gotta hold my i gotta pull myself back
like oh or maybe instead of coming up
with reasons why that's not good i
should just admit that it's probably
good and something that i actually want
for myself and i'm just trying to kind
of like mentally in my own justification
tear their [__] down a little bit to
make myself feel okay but in reality
maybe i should just say oh cool they
showed me something i want um and maybe
i've i've i've actually just kind of
settled here but i could go further than
i than i currently have do do a journal
do you have a history of journaling
or goal-setting
just like writing down like thoughts or
targets that you want to achieve for
different ages
not ages uh but like do you like kind of
have ideas in mind but it's not it's not
based on how old i am like i i've done
this no i don't mean like in the future
current age
what i mean is like when you're 21 where
you're like all right this year i want
to accomplish this when i was 21 i did i
said okay by 30 i i used to say by 30 i
want to have a million dollars in the
bank and
i had a couple of goofy ones it's like i
got a million dollars in the bank i want
to have gone on survivor and i want to
like you know i had like two other like
i don't remember what they were at this
point and then like as i got older i was
like oh well that number needs to be
bigger and then the second one time
isn't really a factor and like oh i
don't care about forbes 30 to 30 that's
actually all [__] and like you know
i kind of adjusted my like goals once i
like wasn't 21 anymore well i think it's
good to look at those things because i
i'll look at all my old journaling and
writings and i'm like what what energy
was i putting into there what was i
bummed about what was i excited about
and then oftentimes i do one of two
things i either try to impress my past
self or try to make my future self
pumped where i'm like what what what
will i be really excited that i did now
um in 10 years so there's this thing i
don't know if you've heard of it so
chris sacca who is uh
you know one of the kind of best
investors of all time who's one of the
biggest investors in twitter and
instagram and a couple other badass
companies he um
he had this thing which was like he he
read out somewhere i think it was like
on the tim ferriss podcast or something
he like he read out a note that he had
written to himself
um a note that he had written written to
himself when he was 20 years old
and um
and he goes i i actually i just found it
while we were talking here this is
perfect i found the transcript have you
do do you know what i'm talking about do
you know what about dick say yeah yeah i
remember it i remember it what did he
say i don't remember exactly what he
said but i remember this episode he goes
uh he goes something about you know what
do you want to be when you grow up he
goes so here i am i'm 20 years old i'm
living in cork ireland
and we'd start the day drinking at 11 30
blah blah blah and i never heard of an
investment banker i've never heard at
that point i had never heard of a
venture capitalist and so i just wrote
in there i don't know what the job is
called but i know it's going to involve
a lot of talking on the phone a lot of
negotiating a lot of yelling at people
high risk high reward unbelievably high
stakes and i'm going to do it part-time
from the mountains part-time from the
beach whatever it does whatever it is
i'm going to be done with it before i'm
40. and then he's like you know fast
forward he this was you know just i
think he was 40 41. and basically a
billionaire accomplished is exactly that
yeah so he's like he's now a billionaire
who does exactly that makes deals he
didn't know what a vc was but he became
a vc which is that deal he has a house
and truckee and you know another one on
the beach so he had the mountains in the
beach thing and it was like literally it
all played out and he retired from the
game and he was like done with it and he
moved on with his life and he started
doing other things
and so um so i always thought that was
really cool and i thought it was cool
because it wasn't like
these [__] lame goals it was a
description of his it was like a
painting of his life it was like a movie
scene of his life and i've noticed that
the people who
kind of do this like they kind of call
their shot and manifest it they don't
really call their shot with like
some like it doesn't feel like excel it
feels like imovie
it's not like a bullet point analytical
thing it's like a
vision for how their life is gonna be
and what life is gonna feel like and
they don't even know the words to
describe it or the route to get there
like but that's it that thing at the end
that's how it's going to feel that's
what it's going to look like that's what
i'm going to do
i'm doing this tonight
i'm doing this is good i imovie not
excel that's a good one if you were
going to do uh like let's do a kind of
off-the-cuff shitty version right again
we do it for the entertainment uh we do
it for the people
what do you think would go into that
what do you what's your what comes to
mind as your version of that
um i like
physical places as opposed to internet
places so i like i it would really
i want to have a i really want to own
i want to have some type of physical
land or pla or buildings throughout the
country that i can entertain all of my
friends all at one time by the way for
all of us can i propose something here
yeah can i propose we do a two-minute
thing where we just jot down on our note
here what we think it is and we'll just
cut that out no because i'm not prepared
i'm not prepared
what's yours
that's what i'm saying
we got to write it down we got to figure
it out okay so i think i'm not ready all
right
look at that reaction this tells you
that's that's what we call resistance
when the boys go to therapy that's we've
identified some resistance
i have to figure this out this is like
such a hard thing to do next question
ben
[__] are you guys ready for the next
question
okay let me let me give you my let me
give you my scene right now okay my
scene that i have in my head is you're
already living i'm living no dude my
house is like this i already know the
house it's this big-ass house that
everything's [__] white inside
my i'm at this i have the same i have a
chef like i have today but it's like on
this like giant area there's people just
coming in and out of my house because
we're like the [__] lobby like my
whole life and work is so integrated
that like my trainer's showing up
they're having brunch with us and then
the you know i'm having this meeting
with this other person but they're also
going to work out with us and the whole
thing is just integrated into one big
ass thing my mom's over my sister's over
because we all live nearby because we
all made it the second thing is i take a
nap midday
with no guilt so zero guilt midday nap i
already know that that is like that is
the
that implies that the rest of the [__]
worked itself all out and then the last
piece is
um all i get to do is just meet
interesting people
and uh be super curious about them and
then i just
either i don't know record or type or
something like kind of like what we're
doing right now i just take the
interesting bits i put it out there and
it's in millions it's in a million
people's ears or eyes you know the next
day because they are following it um
they love the content the like they love
the content package that i put out and i
never meet those people i don't have to
talk to them i'm not their consultant
i'm not their motivational speaker
i just kind of i'm taking little bits of
what i'm curious about and i'm putting
it into a million people's ears every
morning i think uh you're almost i think
you're practically there i don't know
you got to get the house and the fancier
chef dude you could take a nap now i'm
sure dude the midday nap right now with
kids that's indulgent
if you take it like two years that's
like that's not giving the middle finger
to your spouse
i'm gonna take a nap right now
what's the next question by the way that
million people's ear things that was old
i said that before we started this
podcast i had told silly he was like
what do you want to do next when i was
selling the company
and we were on like a [__] 10 mile
walk we just kept walking in the middle
of the night and he was like tell me
more what are you thinking i said dude i
think what i want to do is i just want
to have some way
that i can just get my thoughts out
there and it gets in a million people i
remember calling it ear balls i said
it's in a million people's ear balls in
the morning i said i just think that
that would be so cool if i could just be
on people's ears while they're on their
commute to work or whatever else and
that was before the podcast now the
podcast is getting close to that yeah
you have that all right
and you can go out of order ben pick
pick the questions that are interesting
to you um
let's go with question 10
you should choose your battles wisely
what battles do i choose
dude i choose so many petty battles like
if i when i'm driving and i see someone
behind me and they're driving like an
[__] and cutting other people off i
like go out of my way to slow down and
purposely like block it so i'm going
just as fast as the fast lane so they
can't get by me
um also i reply you're like i go to
their destination
yeah dude i don't have to wear it
it pisses me off at someone's route i
also uh reply to the just so many
comments that i shouldn't reply to
um where i think someone has said
something and it's just kind of
ridiculous and i reply to it and there's
no reason why i should be doing that so
i pick a lot of really really really
dumb battles your hoa battle that you
had i would die on that one that would
that would that
this would not stand that's what i would
i mean i would go hard on that one
what was the question though what
battles do you pick that you shouldn't
it's basically it says choose battles
wisely what battle do i choose so which
really which is saying what battle do
you want to be choosing another way of
looking at is what you said which is
what are the shitty what battles am i
stupidly choosing right now that i need
to not be choosing dude i choose so much
small stuff like i just for some reason
i stay like hardcore in the dirt like
for example i'm out at my ranch and i've
got people here like setting up my
airbnb and stuff and like people are
like doing the stuff but like i just
have to be here and i'm like putting
[__] together or like [__] it i guess
i'm gonna go rent a car go to costco
it's like no we're already doing that i
choose the smallest stuff as opposed to
leveraging my my skill set and so that
is an unwise battle that i should not be
picking instead
i need to be thinking about much bigger
things and i just i simply don't i think
having kids might change that i think
there's a world where that where i'm
praying that having a child is gonna
like somehow like show me the way
uh you guys could tell me if i'm wrong
but dude i picked the smallest i focus
on tiny tiny tiny issues that's like i
have a friend who
the like they're a couple they're like
kind of going through problems right now
as a as a relationship and then she said
something she was like
i just feel like i need to have a kid
and then that's gonna like help us and i
was like oh my god no that is not the
answer
like i understand why you do
that that will make this relationship
better but it is going to do the exact
opposite
i think it could be the answer to be
honest having a dog is like two percent
of having a child not in the sense of
i'm taking care of it but it's like i've
got something that i need to protect and
take care of and it makes me a little
bit happier i imagine properly having a
human being where you're like oh i have
to dedicate my my life to this person
it's beyond me at this point i have a
feeling that is that can be very
inspiring and that's why i think a lot
of like 35 and 40 year olds who are
childless and are like getting messed up
on psychedelics all the time and feel
depressed i'm like dude just [__] pop
out some babies i bet like you won't be
asking yourself how do i find myself
you're going to say how do i just like
make this kid happy and like when you
dedicate yourself to others i think
you're happier uh can i read you
something cool by the way uh that i just
do you disagree with that
um no i think you're right in that in
two ways so i think you're right that
having a kid definitely takes the focus
off yourself so that that eliminates
like a huge number of worries that you
have but it replaces them with new
worries if your habit is to worry guess
what whatever situation i put you in
you're gonna find something to worry
about it's just better to worry about
other people though it's it's more
reasonable it is an improvement it is an
improvement the other thing is that yeah
some [__] just gets thrown out the
window because you don't have that
bandwidth you don't have that extra time
to think about stuff and do stuff and
make that trip to costco because it's
just off the table you don't have the
time and so so that's one thing but it
doesn't fundamentally change the nature
of the problem the root cause of the
problem um which would be you know like
a focus on minor things because guess
what then you're going to start to focus
on you know why your kids you know pinky
toe is a little bit crooked and why they
have this little rash on their knee and
like why they're not eating why they
didn't eat all you know a balanced lunch
and like there's a million there's a
zillion things you could worry about
with a kid and you could even justify
them further because it you're i'm a
martyr i'm a great parent for doing so
so you got to be careful with that i
don't think it goes away but i do think
it like changes the problem a little bit
so what's yours um
okay i'll answer the question i'm gonna
read you this thing so the battles um
the battles i should pick i should pick
the battles i want to choose are
um
health
so
being in the best health that i can be
and having a healthy lifestyle for me
and the people around me
is your wife healthy does she eat
healthy
yeah she she uh she's in and out she can
be when she's on it she's super clean
she doesn't have the problem i have of
discipline like once she flips the
switch she'll just never
eat bad again until she flips the switch
off and then she'll eat oreos all day
and so it's like you know one or the
other um and so
but and same thing with working out
she's like hardcore intense about that
and hardcore intense about her diet um
and like she doesn't waver at all so uh
but it's just a matter of what mood
she's in
um like and the mood is like a year-long
mood not like a daily daily fluctuation
so
i think health is the first one because
i've seen that once your health goes a
little sideways nothing else actually
meant none of the other battles have
like any relevance anymore uh i think
the second one is
like
probably the probably the second battle
to choose is like uh
i don't know probably something around
parenting but i don't even know how to
phrase it like i don't know being
like not constantly um
trying to like rush through parenting
parenting and like getting the job done
uh that's probably the second one is
like the battle of enjoying being
patient with my kids uh and then the
last one is probably like i do too many
projects i have so many [__] projects
at once
and
they're all good projects but they're
probably collectively together a bad
number of projects
that's probably the worst one
i know i always say it but how many
people criticize you about that uh i
don't know if my friends and people who
actually care about me like i don't know
like the people who know me and care
about me they do they do the people are
like oh that's cool you do so many
things and my friends are like that's
not cool all these things could be cool
but you got to do them you got to do
them right and if you're not going to do
them you got to figure out how to like
hire somebody who's going to do that
thing for you dude i would if i was you
i would only do three things i would do
the podcast because that's not that hard
and it kind of drives the other thing i
would do milk road and i would do
investing yeah the problem is i'm too
deep in on e-commerce and so i gotta
like either hire my way out or sell this
thing or i don't know what i don't know
what the other option you got to sell it
i think you sell it or something i think
that
everyone talks about hiring someone to
run [__] you're still like involved
somehow like you're not actually i think
that that's actually really hard to do i
don't know when you did it for the
hustle you were pretty good about it
right yeah but i thought about it all i
mean i still felt like i was working
there but yeah i i didn't do other
projects though
um i want to read something to you real
quick there's a thing from duvall that's
i don't know you said something that
reminded me of this
there's a little i have a slack channel
called wisdom and this is in there so he
goes
uh he says the only true test of
intelligence is if you get what you want
out of life
it's the only true test of intelligence
is if you're getting what you want out
of life it goes there's two parts to
this one is are you able to hack reality
to get what you want and the more
important one was were you smart enough
to figure out what you should want in
the first place
that's the hardest part
that's the hard part exactly and like
you know you read this and you nod and
then it's like have i been smart enough
to figure this out in the first one what
do i even want and then do i do i like
both you and i we have developed the
skills of hacking reality but we get a
little loose easier
remembering what what we actually want
and what doesn't matter what we don't
care about and like remembering which
game to actually play yeah bending
reality is in my opinion the easy part
what knowing what you want is the way
way harder
i don't know
one other part that i really liked he
goes um you live in a society which has
a bunch of people in it so that will
train you to play the the bunch of
people game the multiplayer game
but only
only as an individual do you get to
stumble on the hidden game the single
player game and that is the real game
and he goes he says a couple things he
goes
um
he goes
uh if you had no adversity it would be a
very boring game so remember you got to
play the game it's your game you get to
design the board design the challenge
you get to design the victory condition
and that is the creativity that is like
you know sort of you get to decide the
purpose of your own life and in the same
way you get to decide what game you're
going to play what the rules are and
what the victory condition is and if you
where did you write this intentionally
done that you're uh
you know you're not you're not playing
it you know you haven't actually started
playing that game uh consciously yet
where do you write that i know he he
said this on like a twitter spaces or
something like that this guy's zach
zach pogrobb uh
tweeted it out i liked it that's good
ben let's do another question what's
another one
all right i think this is an interesting
one um what are you letting in so in
other words like uh he says turn off the
news don't read the comments interacting
with negativity think of it as mental
fitness like
what what things are you letting in what
noise you're letting in that you
shouldn't let in oh that you shouldn't i
have a
yeah what are you letting through
through the window or the door that
actually you know you shouldn't be
should be getting through that what are
yours well i had you had written
something on the doc that i think is
interesting it's about feedback so let's
just zoom it in to feedback
what was your question around feedback
so
i have a few ways that i go about doing
this but you could do this when building
a product or when um just asking people
about your personality which i think you
should do like what do i where do i suck
where do i rock and
what you'll notice and it's very clear i
tweeted out what do you like about the
podcast what do you want more of what do
you want less of and for every person
who says they want a longer podcast
there's an equal amount of people who
say they want a shorter one there are
some people who say more guests there
are some people who say no guest and
that makes things really hard to figure
out feedback and so i was gonna ask you
uh how do you decide which feedback to
listen to and which to ignore
so i started off like
i used to the way i used to think about
this was
dude feedback is the key you need a
feedback loop you need to talk to your
customers you need to know your audience
and there was all these like you know
books written about how important that
stuff is and so i became [__] mr
feedback i would you know if i had a
project idea i'm taking the designs out
to a mall and i'm stopping people saying
hey will you give me feedback on this
idea and you know every co-worker i was
like hey i would love some feedback what
do you like about me what do you hate
about me what's good about me to work
with etc i was [__] mr feedback and
then i started to get what you what you
just described which is information
whiplash which is it's like information
overload but it's not just an overload
it's the contradictory information yeah
and so then i'm like oh [__] what to do
so i got paralyzed so then i went to
steve jobs mode [__] feedback people
don't know what they want why would i
ask them what they want they don't they
don't even know what they want for
breakfast how can they tell me what they
want out of this out of this app they've
never heard of how could they tell me
how to be a better boss blah blah people
don't know what they want and i became
mr steve jobs in the turtleneck
then i sort of realize well that's not
good either right because now i've
isolated myself from actually getting
feedback so i have no signal to go off
of
and so now i've come up with a better
balance i think between the two which is
i seek out feedback
from people who i think are going to
give me relevant feedback so i don't
just ask everybody
and then the last piece is the feedback
is not the answer it's the question
so
when i hear feedback i'm not looking for
the answer to what we should do more of
what we should do less of how i can be
better how i can be worse
i'm just looking for the feedback to
just surface a couple of questions so
for example
if they uh if the feedback said you know
longer podcast some people say oh i want
longer pockets some people said i want
shorter podcasts
it's just a question that comes up which
is
what do i think is the right
length of the podcast what podcasts are
great when they're long what podcasts
are great when they're short you know
what would be the what would be a great
short version of our podcast so i use
the feedback to ask myself a better
question and then it's my job to come to
the answer it's their job to just give
me their opinion which
which gives me a question that that can
ask and so same thing with what goes
with products which is when i ask for
feedback
we both like this book called the mom
test and the central principle is i only
get to ask them about their problems
they i don't get to ask them what
solution they want um and so similarly
when i go ask for feedback now i'm just
looking for
them to say things that's going to get
me to ask a better question
that will get me to to come up then it's
my job to come up with the answer to
that um
that's the main principle
when in doubt there's one final thing
which is
at the end of the day i gotta like trust
myself and i got to know that ultimately
if i just do the thing i think is right
over and over and over again i will
happen to i might some people might not
like it but i will ultimately attract
the people who love what i do so that
comes back to that saying my trainer
gave me which is who are my customers
the people that love what i do
and it became that simple for me so that
that's when i that's what i fall back to
so it's like
if it was like an if-else statement it's
like if the if their feedback gives me a
clear question and an answer that i know
what to do with great i'll make an
adjustment
but if not
then i'm just going to do what i do and
i know that that will attract the type
person who loves what i do
i think that i i think you can
i always call it like excel sheet your
way to creating a big business
so i think that like you could just say
like
where's the opportunity based off of
like traffic demand and uh i just hired
these people and you could create wealth
that way so i i and i and i don't like
when people say you have to be
passionate you don't really have to you
can just excel your weight to this but
what i've learned throughout the years
is like
it's a lot more fun just to do things
that you think is are cool
and typically i can that's more the
feedback that i'll listen to is just
like do i think this is cool and the
second thing when i get feedback is i
don't actually care
like you said what they're saying
uh i i care more about why they're
saying it and so for example when people
say make the podcast shorter they're not
saying make it shorter they're saying
it's not always that interesting
and exactly and and so the ques because
if something's
you know really long it doesn't matter
as long as it's badass or if i did a
made a three hour movie about sean
you're sean's gonna watch it and so it's
really not about
listening to the actual feedback but why
do i think they're saying it
so that's what i listen to
all right this one you guys get to talk
about some other people um this one is
am i surrounding myself with the right
people
who are the five i want to spend time
with whoo
powerful question
that is a powerful question
so let's just we'll make it i think it's
a heavy question so let's make it light
so
tell me right now who are the five if
you just said i spend my time the most
with these five people who are the five
people you currently just spend the most
time with
wife sarah
uh neville medora my best friend and
lives next next door to me uh ramon
who you a lot of people know ramon van
meer and then um jack smith
that's four you got one more i wouldn't
put anyone else in those categories no
that's it your dog well
you know i i like you guys kind of like
that's pretty in depth but i would say
that that's no i would edit there
and all right so then let's let's let's
just add one more who's somebody you
wish was in that five that is that
you're not spending as much time as as
you like in an ideal world you would be
uh steph smith
i would add steph smith though
yeah
nice
i think
smith is is amazing
just like what
i was like just like our podcast
listeners
they also want more
every time i talk to her i like damn
she's brilliant she's a very special
person uh so maybe her
uh anyone else like uh i sometimes i do
wish like i had like some baller baller
baller friends a lot of my friends are
like pretty great but like [__]
hanging out with like a russian oligarch
just to see how like some of these crazy
people think who are like
extreme
i would like i like extreme people so
even though i may think they're a bad
person i would like to hang out with
some of these extreme
people who are just on extreme ends of
success or it could even be an athlete
like what's it like to hang out with
like the person who holds the world
record in the marathon so it would be
nice to to be around more extreme people
that's a good that's a really good
actually twist to this which is
i think a lot of people have heard this
idea of you are the average of the five
people you spend the most time with and
that's true
but there's two other groups of people
that i think really matter
one is like the equivalent of a bender
it's like you don't want to go on a
bender every day or every weekend but
like
twice a year a bender is a lot of fun
and if you don't do a bender twice a
year if you're not really having one
amazing party or you know just an
all-nighter or some kind of experience
that's like a little out there
you kind of are leaving a little bit of
life on the table and um and so
there's some people that are amazing in
that capacity that you just you would
never want in your uh
your everyday but they're amazing twice
a year uh do i see your hangs with uh
and i think there's some people that are
like that
the other one is
who have you just not even encountered
yet like who is just outside of your
bubble that it's like you don't even
know what you don't know yet because you
just don't hang out with anybody like
that and so you you have zero exposure
and therefore you know it's just like
it's not part of your world view it's
not part of your mental model yet so i
think that's yours two categories
who are on the five or the those two two
categories do the five and then the
other
all right so my five would be sonia my
wife and my kids i'll just put it all
together
um
my mom is the next one uh so i spend my
mom comes over one week out of every
month she stays with us
um
uh ben who's kind of like my
my right hand man my my business partner
across milk road across
in the fund he helps with the podcast he
does a bunch of things
so i talked to ben
hours a day
um andre who i don't think you've met
andre right
no no
andre is like kind of like the new ben
he's like the next ben um so he's a new
guy in the fold on that level and andre
is kind of amazing because
andre's got this story um
that he had some illness that he had
something he caught some bug he got us
some infection that like
he gave him like kind of like chronic
fatigue syndrome or something like that
like he basically like couldn't get out
of bed for like i don't know like two
years or something like that like he was
in a wheelchair
and nobody
nobody knew what it was and it was just
like and then he kind of like recovered
from it but it was like this multi-year
thing and so this [__] is the
most like grateful person you'll ever
meet because he's like dude i walked
today and i'm like you know like it
doesn't take much for andre to be like
high on life and because andre's around
me all the time i'm s i get that
secondary high you know the contact high
right off of andre
and like you know because he he kind of
like was just battling and
got out of it and so now he's like every
day he like
you could tell he's just savoring every
day like as if you you haven't eaten in
like two weeks and you're having your
first meal that's how andre's like and
so i love that about andre who and who
are the other two
uh the other one is suli uh who's our
mutual buddy
um
and
i don't hang out with him that much
because he moved but he's a partner in
one of my businesses and so i talked to
him you know because that but the one
downside is now that he's like an
official business partner
we don't really just like
talk to shoot the [__] anymore it's like
we kind of anytime i'm talking to him
i'm sort of talking to him always as
he's as if he's my investor or business
partner instead of
just catching up you know so i guess
that's probably the downside and then so
those are the those are the five that
i'm currently hanging out with
the most i would put you next as we hang
out you know two three hours a week
doing this so that's more than most
people and then the one i wish i hung
out with more was ramon because ramon is
like the best human on earth so you know
the more ramon in my life the better
human i would be just you know by
default i completely agree when he
teaches me a lot he uh he's a very
thoughtful person i learned a lot from
him
and then the the category that i was
saying that people i have no exposure to
is like i basically have no exposure
anymore to people that are in high
school in college which is like actually
pretty important as an investor and like
you know person of the world to know
like
what it's like oh i forgot i used to
think about these stupid things and they
were the most important things in my
life or like
oh wow you know we didn't have phones so
we couldn't do these things you know
that they're doing now in high school or
college so i have like zero exposure to
that
um
you know like people in third world
countries like you know when i went down
to mexico i was like oh wow like i kind
of forgot like just how simple and like
different life is for most people on
earth and like you know i used to live
in indonesia in china and stuff like
that so like i definitely was in it
every day but now you know i'm just
sitting in the burbs in california so
it's easy to forget that so i think i
have a lot like my bubble is pretty
tight right now i think i should pop
that intentionally once a while
do you want to do one more question ben
yeah we're doing five questions five
questions seems like a nice uh
round number
and you bet you can remix it because
some of these are sort of the same so
you could just ask a different question
you're a good question ask her in
general
i've been thinking about uh one of these
so let's go with this one in what ways
am i in my own way ugh
i can say that one easy i
lose my temper
and
follow my i get very emotional where i'm
like no [__] this this is wrong we have
to do it this way
uh
and i have lost a lot of money for doing
that for like uh
uh let's just say like it's an employee
who i think like has
uh maybe underperformed uh
even though they talk like they're hot
[__] i would just fire them as opposed
like well we could definitely salvage
this like there's lots of ways to
salvage things and make things better
it's just a
net positive but more often than not be
like well no i just i'm out i don't want
to deal with the headache i'm over it or
and that is a very emotional decision i
make so many emotional decisions
oftentimes it's sometimes it's ego
oftentimes it's temper or but mostly if
it's like oh i think this person is
trying to get one over them on me like
[__] them i want to crush them no i'm
not doing you know what i mean
yes i make a ton of emotional decisions
as opposed to practical decisions
that's interesting
uh all right i got two i have one that's
real but but is that true have you seen
that with me
yeah for sure you've been mad at me
sometimes and i'm like because you think
i'm trying to like get one over on you
and i'm like dude i'm really not and
then once you realize i'm not like your
whole perspective changed right away and
i was like oh that's what you thought
like oh i had no idea because i wouldn't
like it's so different than the way i
think so i i didn't
i just never i couldn't understand it
basically it's not like
we can give a real example i got mad at
you for being late and i'm like in my
head i'm like he doesn't care he doesn't
care about this he thinks he's better
and it was reality was like no dude my
baby was sick or like
you know i like she was in the bath and
it took forever to get her out uh and
that's like a legitimately good excuse
like
even a bad excuse which was just like
dude i just i literally
like i was sitting here i just lost
track of time i'm not doing anything i'm
not more important i'm not like a diva
i'm not uh trying to do that like i feel
horrible every time i do like i
sometimes i literally don't even have a
good excuse
uh but but even that was fine with you
it was just like as long as you know i
was sort of like
actively
doing it it didn't bother you you know
what i mean
or another thing that i do all the time
and i think everyone should learn from
me and i'm working hard at it and i made
this mistake is resp replying
really quickly to text based messages so
whether that's an email
uh anything where it's like dude it's
okay if you
sit on this for an hour or even a day or
even five days sometimes i'll get [__]
like a text or an email and i'm like oh
no fva and i quickly reply and i'm like
oh i should have just sat on that for
like three hours what was i thinking
yeah i'm that's actually a great one
that's a great answer for me too i'm
massively disorganized um which affects
everything so it's like replying like
there are
so many emails and text messages that
like
people are either like offering me
something they're trying to help me and
i'm just not replying and people take it
very personally um as you know maybe i
would too if i felt like i was getting
blown off by this person or i'll just
miss a deal that like
it's just like a clear win for me
because i just don't reply
i don't see it
i would say [__] them you know i
actually don't think you should i i've
been struggling with that too i had and
lately i'm just like i'm just not going
to feel bad about replying to these
people like and it's
the most
wait listen here's the most douchiest
thing i could say but
just subtract this by like a lot and
that's the reality imagine you're justin
timberlake and people like are always
presenting you with stuff you're just
like dude i don't care i'm gonna do what
i want to do of course we are not that
big a deal but like a much much smaller
version where there's like lots of
opportunities and i'm just like i'm just
gonna adore all them i don't expect jt
to reply to a dm do i
yeah that's true but uh i'm talking
about like people who
i'm doing business with her but they're
my friends or something like that like
those are people i do intend to be
replying to or i've asked them for
something then they give it to me and i
forget to do something with it but don't
you say jokes what do you think laziness
there like imagine my children imagine
you're joe rogers
how much is that
i don't want to share the check on on
screen but this is a 13 000 check that's
just been sitting here for like six
months and then it expired and so now i
just had to go like get a new check and
then i got this is the new check after
the other one expired and i still
haven't deposited this one another month
has gone by like that's how shitty i am
and it's just sitting here because i'm
just disoriented for no reason or same
thing with like my company's book so
here's the bad way it plays out which is
i don't like i've never hired a
bookkeeper
and so i'm like oh yeah like i don't
know like aren't the transactions just
like on the credit card no they gotta
ask you they're gonna end the year i'll
just i'll just cram for my taxes final
and just figure this out and so now i'm
like learning oh how do people do this
oh they hire bookkeepers and then they
like
okay gotcha so like there was just
things that are just messy in my world
that's me getting in my own way um you
know it cost me a lot of money to to
have messy books or not reply to certain
certain emails um so i think that's me
getting in my own way the other one was
just staying up late which is again this
is so boring cliche almost embarrassed
to even say it on the podcast because
how late do you stay up nobody gives a
[__] like on average i was staying up
until two or three in the morning and
then i'd wake up at nine
and
i just started like last week i was just
like [__] i'm just asleep early and
it solved like five of my biggest
problems it's like my diet cleaned up
because i no longer late night snack or
eat like junk which is all i would do
right if i had dinner at seven and now
it's one am and i'm hungry like guess
what i'm not good
yeah exactly it's like my sleep was
shitty my work was shitty i was editing
the milk road at night now i just i
sleep at like 10 30 or 11. i wake up at
6 30 or 7 in the morning i write the
real road and it's our head at the milk
road and it's done but and like
by the time the kids wake up like i've
already like finished my work day almost
and so i just cleaned that up and it
cleaned up like five other things
but again
so [__] cliche to say sleeping early
that i
just bleep this whole thing out make it
mysterious instead do you remember uh
how regimented rob dyrdek was about
tracking his time and like waking up at
6 00 a.m or 5 a.m or whatever he did i
actually like like
i i if that's what makes him happy do it
and i also respect how crazy he's about
that i think i like extreme people
part of me was like oh but that's like
you don't need to do that but then the
other part is like that would be kind of
cool to do for like two or three weeks
just to see what would happen just what
would happen if you do get up at 6 00
a.m and you are like you have a very
strict schedule i i actually do think
that that sounds kind of fun to try it
once in a while what time do you sleep
and wake up typically
last night i couldn't go to bed i went
to bed at one or two
and i got out of bed at seven i you
normally always get out of bed at seven
are you like super regimented with your
schedule i'm not productive though
usually i'm not productive until about
nine or ten
my uh yeah so my baby wakes up at
six in the morning usually so that's
when i'm up
and um
i try and go to bed around like 10 10 30
and then once or twice a month i'll go
to bed at like 3am because i need to get
something done
that's why you go to bed at 3am
you're not like going on doing [__] wait
do you do drink do you drink or do drugs
no well it's usually like i
god this is the lamest trio ever when i
when i do how to take over the world
episodes i usually do a bunch of it in
one sitting that i'll do from like 9 00
p.m
to like three or four a.m i'll do that
twice a month sean do you so let me
recap these five parts
i drink if like the occasion calls for
it but not with any regularity no but do
you get drunk i i used to but no like
last five years i have not been getting
drunk and did you do any drugs no god
that's crazy what a bunch of fruits dude
i just drink green smoothies bro i don't
even drink coffee
we are so lame all right go ahead all
right i'm gonna recap the five questions
so the five questions were in what areas
of my life am i settling right now
the next one was um
am i surrounded oh no that's not it oh
yeah
choose your battles wisely
what battles
am i choosing right now and what what do
i want to choose so what areas of my
life am i settling
choose your battles wisely what battles
do you want to choose number three what
am i letting in that i need to shut out
that's noise and information and
opinions from the outside world
and then
am i surrounding myself with the right
people who are the five people i want to
spend the most time with
and what was the fifth one did we do
five
yeah question five was in what ways am i
in my own way oh yeah in what way is am
i in my way what are the things you're
doing that gets in your own way
um
those are the five ben which one of
those questions when we set them did you
go off on a tangent think it for
yourself what your answer is which one
shook you
one of these questions um i i the first
question shook me in what areas of my
life am i settling
that okay so okay you guys are looking
at me i i thought maybe i'd get away
with not actually giving you the answer
because like that's like that's one that
penetrates your soul but you both were
just like you're gonna answer right now
and like for you both of you talked
about like health and fitness stuff
and
one area in which i settle a lot in my
life is
like i get super concerned about
environmental pollutants especially like
plastics and microplastics and like
stuff like that and i always feel like a
psychopath when i talk about it because
everyone else is like oh what what like
plastics and
i feel crazy because i'm like no
actually like
this isn't a conspiracy theory like the
research is out there that like all
these microplastics are like crashing
our testosterone levels and like
disrupting our endocrine systems and
stuff like i'm not crazy but the fact
that everyone else is like yeah whatever
makes me feel even crazier and so a lot
of times it's a weird obsession i just
like settle i compromise and i'm like
look at my baby like putting this
plastic toy in her mouth and like a part
of me dies and i'm just like
ugh whatever i i settle i'm not going to
fight this fight right now but it is
something that you have plastic
tupperware
we have plastic tupperware that i wish
we would just like throw away so just do
it dude that is not at all where i
thought you were going with that answer
when you first said it because you were
like so it was like weighing so heavy on
your heart and that's what it was it
matters a lot to me sean most [__]
random answer
are is is
is rubber it's like a like what they
call like a binky with a pacifier thing
the pacifier what what is that rubber i
don't even know what that is that
plastic uh yeah so most of the time no
they won't do plastic in pacifiers so
they'll either do silicone uh which is
better or they'll do rubber yeah which
is also better and rubber
okay right silicone i like have my
doubts about um but it does not have
like the same proven track record of
disrupting your endocrine systems the
way plastics do do you do
use water bottles um no in fact i try
not to use disposable water bottles
because a lot of times they leach
what do i go watch or read that's gonna
scare the [__] out of me there's a joe
rogan
episode that i'll link up in the show
notes where he talks with she's a the
harvard researcher who
does a bunch of this stuff and she's
really good uh and it will
it will scare you a lot yeah dude
plastic's pretty bad then like
i you don't know that sean do you mind
you microwave plastic don't you only on
this podcast
yeah i i microwave everything and i
everything's in plastic in my house so
i'm like oh [__] okay um
so i've heard this but i've like never
i never got shook yet where i'm like oh
take action in this
um
but that's why i ask what do i need to
go watch
that's gonna like trigger me where i'm
gonna need to i need to be like i i will
go and you know make it like dramatic
change
i'll link it up but like the short of it
is basically like our testosterone
levels are decreasing at one percent per
year fertility levels are just like
crashing and it's not just people who
want to have children less like people
who are trying to have children are able
to have them at much lower rates than in
the past to the point where it's like
and our plastic use is increasing so
much that they're like in 50 years we're
not sure that anyone is going to be able
to have
uh unassisted uh children anymore but
how do they know plastics cause that
right you know versus just
because they do studies of
with rats and uh they're able to
demonstrate it the the
correlation good answer that was a very
good answer and um
what do you what's what's an example of
something you swap out that's like a big
culprit for plastic like
most people are doing this but if you
swap this that solves like you know
twenty percent right well so the biggest
thing that she said was
never heat plastic that is like if you
can do one thing it's never heat up
plastic so like if you have a water
bottle
uh with water in it like yes that will
leach some plastic into your system it's
not great but
if you leave it out in the sun that
heats up to 100 degrees you're gonna get
like 10 times as much plastic so it's
it's not eating things hot from plastic
but how do you reconcile that fact with
the fact that you smoke you told me that
you smoke a pack of cigarettes a day
[Laughter]
uh yeah
noted chainsmoker uh ben wilson that's
what people know me for how do you do
both
well and how do you how can you have how
do you have 24 newports a day do you
tell me not to microwave plastic
you know it's just one of those
mysteries sam i don't know how to
explain it and how do you um can you
test to see how much i don't know that's
a good question i would love to do it if
you can i don't know that you can i got
a new business that we're gonna talk
about on monday that's gonna address
that by the way
i was all prepared for it today really
did you say i don't wanna what is it
it's called float uh did you see it in
the dock it's called float dot is what
is it what's the url is it called float
bend where's my [__] reap it's called
um
no it's called fount
uh font found sorry fount dot bio fount
it's basically a five thousand dollar a
month concierge service where they test
your blood and tell you all about your
body
it's very expensive but sounds
incredibly cool for five thousand
dollars a month you better be touching
my body
well
we'll see maybe
maybe it'll make women to actually want
to touch your body maybe that's maybe
maybe we'll do one better
we're getting tested over here five
grand a month why five grand a month
that's such an absurd number you're
doing this
no i'm not doing it but i think it's
close to beta uh
five grand a month would i do it i would
sign up for three months for sure i
think you could do it in three months in
increments i for fifteen thousand
dollars yeah i would try that
dude i had a concierge doctor one time
for like a year when i was really sick
and it was 25 grand for a year and it
was mostly amazing
also i understand why rich people and
how rich people can get access to so
many drugs because like if i wanted to i
could just like text the doctor and be
like hey can you refill this uh this
xanax for me
or like hey i need some more oxy like is
like and you're paying them so much
money that it seems like they're willing
to do that it is kind of crazy
this took a turn hey all right can i do
we have to we're way over time do i have
time to ask you guys one more question
as long as it's five minutes okay i
think it can be five minutes or less i'm
just curious about this i don't know why
this i thought of this as we were asking
the five questions
but
if you were to like simulate your life
a thousand
what do you think the ceiling is and
what do you think the floor is in other
words like are there a few little things
if they broke in the wrong way like sam
parr is working at a mcdonald's
in missouri right now or like a few
breaks
where if things had broken the wrong way
you would
uh be like a
worth a hundred billion dollars one of
the richest men in the world like what
do you think your floor is what do you
think your ceiling is and do you think
you ended up about what your average is
i think in my case i could tell you i
think it's my favorite is that the
ground rules the ground rules are same
genetics and same like family not like
i'm born in a different country like
yeah it's just like a few little random
variables get changed you make a few
different decisions as you go through
life but same family same situation same
person i think i was not far from being
like homeless alcoholic drug addict like
i think that was actually potentially in
the cards or just like in jail because i
would con people and steal i think a lot
of people honestly could say that though
like if they like if they like gotta if
you ever like do certain drugs like oh
man like the it's actually i could see
myself uh living on the streets uh
the best of like the limit um
uh
i think like a really attainable thing
is i could have not sold my company and
i think it could have been worth
hundreds of millions of dollars and i
could have been worth many hundreds of
millions of dollars by the time i was
50.
i think that could have done that i
think i could have pulled that off if i
was willing to put it in put the work in
yeah but you'll probably end up there
now anyways you're 30 now that's 20 more
years
yeah given where you're at now it's
pretty likely that you end up over 100
million dollars it's very likely that
i'll be working 20 more years
it's almost guaranteed it'll be worth
nine years i mean it's almost certain
yeah so then [__] it i don't know
exactly
so you peeked you got one of the good
good rolls of the dice
um i don't think i mean obviously
there's some scenarios where yeah i end
up you know in jail drug addict whatever
but i don't think that's like the
realistic floor for me i think
the realistic floor for me is
was probably like um working on twitch
forever you know
no not even like you know working at uh
working as a lab assistant at [__]
you know
uh
greenville universities like biology
department or some [__] like that like
you know basically some some job that
was like
i got on some track
that didn't really have a
merit-based system it was a time-based
system um so like you know you basically
just get rewarded for how long you've
been in the game
and not like how much impact you've been
able to make and um and it might have
been in a very kind of like complete i
was very close to a complete
non-business field right i was like
about to go to med school so you know i
was
very likely going to be in a different
thing but like even if i hadn't done the
med school path you know just being a
engineer somewhere or being a
you know project manager somewhere was
extremely likely for me
um
had i just made one or two different
decisions kind of at some point the more
interesting question is like how far off
the peak am i and i think i'm pretty far
off the peak to be honest with you and
in fact you know uh ben you were there
when we had uh david friedberg on the on
the podcast
and i told him sam i was trying to
butter him up i was like dude so you've
created
not one not two but pretty much
three billion dollar companies
um if you know he created climate which
is a billion dollar company he created
metro mile which is basically a billion
dollar company and he created the
production board's a billion dollar
company
and i said you've done
that and you know if i went back to you
at age kind of 18 19 20 you were in
college and i told you hey man this is
how it all shakes out you're gonna
create three billion dollar company
three separate billion dollar companies
uh in like the in this like kind of
space science space
uh what would you have said would that
have been unbelievable to you would you
could you have believed that because
honestly i'd probably have been
disappointed and i was like what why
because i think two things like one is
he wasn't really like money wasn't the
like the driving force and then the
second piece is like
i don't think he feels like he's had a
big
impact on the world yet
um
like okay metro mile exists and okay
climate exists but like
you know what he's trying to do now with
like canada and other stuff like that is
like he's like trying to find it like be
like
the way we produce food is gonna change
or like the way we produce
pharmaceuticals in a change like that's
about now the like the type of swing he
goes for which is like the world used to
produce things in factories and farming
and blah blah and now we do it in a
laboratory blah blah blah like that he's
trying to fundamentally change the means
of production
and so i think that's what he meant but
um
i was kind of blown away by that answer
and that's the type of thing when i
remember i said like
you hang out with that x factor person
who like just sort of like stuns you
into a different like what i said
when do i realize i'm settling is when a
guy who's created three billion dollar
company says i probably would have been
disappointed if i knew this was the this
was the outcome um it makes me think
wait what is this guy even going what is
this guy scoreboard if he doesn't think
this is a win and then what does that
make me think about my scoreboard how
could i update my scoreboard not to
match his but to like let's let's
definitely question it right like let's
see keep it the same as it's been for 10
years
is he a billionaire now he's personally
a billionaire
probably like 500 in that ballpark i i
think he said on the podcast that he
that he hasn't hit a billion so
i think close but i don't think he's hit
it yeah isn't that funny how you can
achieve just
what most every single person on earth
would consider like the top of the top
at the top of the top and you're like
yeah that's funny once i googled
my uh my mentor and kind of business my
investors net worth and i remember being
like and then i googled a whole bunch of
celebrities like so i think i think at
that time like his his kind of like my
ballpark approximate like my
triangulated net worth for them was like
700 800 million
and then i googled like britney spears
and it was like 25 or 50.
and then i was like wait brit i was like
he's like
more than 10 times richer than britney
spears i was like okay alex rodriguez i
remember when he signed the biggest mlb
contract ever was a 10-year 225 million
contract or 250 million contract at that
time and i remember being like oh my god
he's getting three he already has three
times a rock's contract and it's just
like i just googled every celebrity i
could think of like
more than all of them did you know that
you're richer than ryan sheckler
i think i literally said that i was like
you're 15
000 germaine dupri's
dude he's probably even richer than
denzel washington this guy's amazing
that's what i'm saying
oh easily watch you know denzel networth
dude i bet you denzel's gotta be worth
like uh a hundred at least been in the
game for a while
piss poor 280. he's a double denzel you
know like come on man
that's awesome
all right i'm out
[Music]
you